[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5monde et sur vos
chaînes de la tnt tout de suite voici
les titres de ce journal
jeudi présidents et présidentes de
région étaient réunis à montpellier pour
le congrès de régions de france un
évènement très important dans les
territoires auxquels nos confrères de
vie occitane y ont assisté vous serez
tout de ce qui s'est passé à ce congrès
des régions de france dans un instant
dans l'actualité également avis aux
amateurs de bonnes bouteilles avec
modération bien entendu 6 septembre est
le mois des vendanges et bien octobre
est bien celui des foires aux vins tv7
la chaîne du groupe sud ouest nous
emmènera à c'est le bordeaux non non non
vous n'avez pas la berlue un bateau
volant ça existe c'est une curiosité
même que nous emmène découvrir la chaîne
corse via télépayer nos confrères sur
place et puis en fin de journal place
aux strass et aux paillettes et à la
sublime sharon stone qui a illuminé le
rocher à monaco pour la bonne cause
attention au festival du glamour en
perspective à la fin de ce journal
plus sérieusement nous partons pour
l'occitanie qui dit congrès des régions
dit bien évidemment présidents et
présidentes de région venus tous en
nombre l'objectif de cette journée qui a
démarré jeudi à montpellier livrer leur
vision et leurs attentes sur plusieurs
dossiers notamment le chômage et la
transition écologique sur place
d'ailleurs à montpellier olivier roirand
de via occitanie leur a tendu son micro
écoutez
carole delga renaud muselier jean castex
le 17e congrès des régions organise à
montpellier n'a pas seulement pris des
allures de réunion entre les élus il y
avait aussi un petit air de
présidentielle elle l'a simplement au
moment où certains cherchent à découdre
le pays le gouvernement de la république
chercheur à l'unité et le rassemblement
un tacle doucement glissé de jean castex
à eric zemmour le polémiste toujours pas
déclaré dans la course à l'elysée dans
les coulisses du parc des expositions
impossible pour la droite de ne pas
évoquer le flou qui règne autour du
futur candidat qui sera désigné par un
congrès en décembre une situation
préjudiciable juge renaud muselier le
président de la région sud n'est pas sur
le terrain avant décembre c'est un peu
dommage quand on voit les plaques
tectoniques avec des montées des
descentes peut qu' il faut il se passer
quand on est dans une campagne il faut
quand même un bagne enfin à gauche
carole delga la firme les équipes d'anne
hidalgo compte bien discuté avec yannick
jadot l'eurodéputé des verts vient de
remporter la primaire de son parti et le
doute sur une possible alliance avec le
ps au premier tour n'est toujours pas
levée l'échéance présidentielle mérite
une mobilisation totale dans le cadre de
cette mobilisation totale c'est bien sûr
un travail en commun avec yannick jadot
puisque nous avons besoin de pouvoir
travailler sur ce modèle de société que
nous voulons transformer entre le flou à
droite les candidatures qui se
multiplient à gauche emmanuel macron
muet sur ses intentions la rentrée
politique dessine déjà les contours
d'une année électorale de tous les
possibles
tout à fait autre chose dans l'actualité
dans le domaine de l'hôtellerie et de la
restauration
les employés sont en voie de disparition
tel pourrait être le cri d'alarmé lancé
par l'ensemble des acteurs de
l'hôtellerie restauration qui peine à
recruter notamment chez les jeunes pour
tl7 la chaîne de la loire adrien
bletterie est entré dans les cuisines du
lycée professionnel de verrières en
forez à une heure de saint-etienne
regardez ce reportage
tout est quasi normal pour cette rentrée
le masque reste bien sûr encore
obligatoire mais la cuisine elle elle
reprend vie est magnifique te plains tu
le mets là bas pour qu'ils puissent
entamer la réalisation
on remet un petit peu les élèves dans
l'ambiance pour qu'il renoue donc avec
les locaux le matériel les vacances sont
passés par dessus est bon du coup ils
ont tendance à oublier un petit peu mais
ça revient très vite ça n'arrête pas ce
matin autour des fourneaux on s'occupe
de la viande de la cuisson des légumes
du dressage certains découvre une
nouvelle passion j'aime cuisiner pour
les autres
la nourriture aussi
apprendre les gestes qu'ils posent en
coupé et macé à cuire les différentes
qui sont au niveau du service les élèves
retrouvent le restaurant fini les
travaux pratiques on sert des vrais
clients maintenant huit couverts
aujourd'hui pour le la et ingrid ingrid
qui a d'ailleurs hésité pour rejoindre
la formation mois début j'étais un peu
stressé pourquoi parce que je savais pas
si ça a l'air simple pour faire les
stages outre beaucoup de jeunes se sont
posé la même question qu ingrid le lycée
constate cette année 20 25 % d'élèves en
moins dans la restauration et dans
l'hôtellerie
c'est un petit peu compliqué parce qu'on
est dans des métiers en tension profil
s'est plus des gens qui ont un peu plus
de difficultés qu avant mais cette année
en tout cas les élèves ne manqueront de
rien et non seulement stage mais même
offre d'emploi recrutement d'anciens
élèves j'ai tous les jours des offres
qui m'arrive sur d'anciens élèves russie
qui cherchent même de restaurateurs qui
sont partenaires ou de deux maisons de
retraite ou de cuisine centrale enfin
tout non tous nos métiers tous nos
métiers sont en recherche de d'employés
ça c'est sûr dans toute la loire une
centaine de postes sont disponibles
actuellement dans les bars les
restaurants et hôtels fait dans
l'actualité ces images de la métropole
de marseille aix en provence qui est
touchée par une grève du ramassage des
ordures une grève qui suscite un
ras-le-bol général sur place regardez
ces images de valentin rodriguez pour
nos confrères de la provence deux
partenaires sur place moi j'habite dans
le m boulevard de la liberté savait que
là en bas de chez moi c'est la poubelle
mais c'est vraiment c'est pourri il faut
qu'ils obtiennent de ski ceux qui
veulent voir mais c'est vrai que déjà
que la ville est sale
si ça continue
les épidémies les rats
moi le battait je vous lève tôt et
je vois dire à vous allez entendre
maintenant dans ce journal le témoignage
rare d'un jeune afghan de 25 ans mohamed
accueilli par un couple toulousain il y
a de cela quatre ans grâce à
l'association singa association qui
continue aujourd'hui à mettre en rapport
et en lien les familles françaises et
les réfugiés il se confie devant la
caméra d'agnès grimaldi de nos confrères
de la dépêche du midi interview de
mohamed regardez j'ai passé plusieurs
pays pour venir ici
ensuite on nous le pakistan iran turquie
italie
et voilà pour arriver s'il s'appelait
jeter 12 ans aux élèves
je suis ahuri en france 2010 est un jeu
où j'étais dans chaque ville dans chaque
pays jeter quelques mots et quelques
jours et se passer pour venir ici cette
nuit ci est juste que c'est trop
dangereux et ses risques pour venir ici
on peut en fruit de notre pays parce que
la guerre qui part vivre à la barre par
liberté on n'a pas le choix confie ici
pour venir ici mais encore elle donc
gérer des gens qui mord et je voudrais
en mesure dans la merde ça c'est
difficile pour rire si x passeur pour
les gens parce qu'il y ait un peu si tu
connais pas les langues plus difficile
pour trouver une touche moi et puis vous
l'avez vu dans les titres je vous invite
maintenant à découvrir un étonnant
hydroglisseur me zodiac me parapente
donc vous apercevez des images prises
par agnès riccardi devient telle est pas
aisé nos confrères en corse un drôle de
bateau qui montent à plusieurs mètres
d'altitude et qui offre une sensation de
liberté aux participants une nouvelle
manière plutôt insolite il faut bien le
dire d'explorer le magnifique littoral
corse
direction maintenant les antilles la
martinique où depuis une dizaine de
jours les mesures de confinement ont été
assouplies sur place résultat la
pratique des loisirs nautiques peut
enfin reprendre pour le plus grand
plaisir des professionnels mais aussi
des familles vous voir un reportage
signé de josé lechertier pour vient atv
martinique
c'est l'heure de la rentrée après
quelques recommandations de sécurité et
une initiation à la pagaie il est temps
de passer à la pratique
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ce groupe navigue dans la
baie de génie pas et part à la
découverte de la mangrove et après
quelques semaines sans rien faire ça
fait du bien parce que rester enfermé à
rester enfermés même pour les enfants
par des activités ces tops de pouvoir
reprendre il était temps que ça s'arrête
et on espérait bien que on allait
pouvoir recommencer à vivre un petit peu
normalement en attendant les prochaines
étapes pour sébastien gérant de la
société ça a été un coup dur pour son
activité de loisir depuis la semaine
dernière la clientèle fait peu à peu son
apparition lors plus sauf le tout
doucement mais franchement nous sommes
on est très très content on commence à
voir des clients on recommence à faire
des sorties donc
donc voilà on est très contents
l'environnement et de 11,5 la nature au
prix un peu un peu de force tout comme
l'activité kayak ici il faut montrer
patte blanche le pass and iter est
demandé avant la signature du contrat
une première plutôt étonnante pour kevin
et pierre c'est vrai que ça fait un peu
bizarre quand même mais j'avoue que
c'est la première pour moi en tout cas
c'est vrai que c'est un peu c'est un peu
bizarre mais bon va se faire ça fait du
bien on a obligé avec des rôles que le
passé ni terre par contre les jets de
s'y plier
c'est pas facile pas facile mais cela ne
semble pas être franc c'est bien perçus
à partir du moment où on prend le temps
en fait au client d'expliquer tout
simplement que voilà on est sur une
mauvaise période et on est obligé de
demander ce pas cela le chat qui est une
affaire qui fonctionne surtout pendant
un temps magnifique comme celui
d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
le seul objectif d'euros mais de
retrouver sa vitesse de croisière on a
été coupé en plein mois d'août on avait
une belle saison qui était lancée
c'était vraiment une belle période on
espère que la population va
martiniquaise va vite revenir nous nous
rendre visite pour pouvoir relancer
relancer l'activité pouvoir passer un
peu de temps sur l'eau maintenant c'est
à vous il est temps d'en profiter avant
la prochaine vague
voilà une bonne nouvelle pour les
amateurs de glisse et stations se
prépare à accueillir à nouveau les
vacanciers la fermeture et l'hiver
dernier à cause du coc vide a engendré
rapport le 5 milliards d'euros de pertes
pour ce secteur de la montagne ainsi à
paris les professionnels de savoie avait
à coeur de présenter les atouts de leur
station à la presse comme vous pouvez le
voir sur ces images prises par sébastien
germain 2 8 mont blanc la tante aura
assez duré rendez vous le 16 octobre sur
les pistes à tignes première station à
ouvrir dans la montagne en france nous
partons dans le nord maintenant par
souci écologique ou économique de plus
en plus de français m d'aller faire du
shopping dans des boutiques solidaires
mais certains ne viennent pas uniquement
pour le plaisir de dénicher de bonnes
affaires comme a pu le constater
caroline fichten de la chaîne wéo la
chaîne de la voie du d'ordre confrères
sur place
virginie vient pour la première fois ici
elle cherche des vêtements pour elle et
pour sa fille à la boutique de gêne tout
est gratuit et pourtant ça n'a pas été
facile d'en passer la porte ou sanka un
peu gêné donc j'ai mis du temps à venir
mais un voile heures après quand on
vient on voit que c'est chaleureux on
sent bien les gens sont gentils la
boutique de gênes cdu seconde main en
bon état pas question de proposer des
vieilleries immettables ou abîmés ce
concept de boutique 100% gratuite et
porté uniquement par des bénévoles grâce
à lequel fournit au centre social de
sang guette un projet d habitants pour
les habitants des personnes de
professionnels ici c'est que des
bénévoles donc nos stocks sont issus de
dons et ensuite les gens viennent se
servir comme ils veulent il n'y a pas de
troc on n'est pas obligé de donner pour
prendre voilà l'idée c'est vraiment la
réutilisation ne pas jeter consommer
moins et mieux c'est donc l'un des
objectifs de cette boutique gratuite une
boutique où l'on veut proposer de jolies
choses
six ans sophie regarde comme elle est
jolie celle ci
il faut que ça donne envie c'est pas ici
c'est pas la misère humaine pas du tout
au contraire
toutes sortes de personnes doit avoir
envie de venir ici et puis de justement
c'est pour faire évoluer ce concept de
vêtements de seconde main d'objets de
seconde main parce qu'il ya trop de
consommation et puis ici on trouve aussi
de la convivialité et du contact c'est
le petit truc en plus apporté par des
bénévoles investis tous les jours tu es
pas l'objet les c'est un lieu d'échangés
aussi un lieu des changes de vêtements
mais change de parole voilà les gens
viennent discuter passer un moment pas
fait un bon moment virginie ce jour là à
trouver des vêtements à son goût et
reviendra sûrement sans appréhension
cette fois et puis vous l'avez vu dans
les titres de ce journal avis aux
amateurs de bonnes bouteilles avec
modération je le disais tout à l'heure
bien sûr et 6 septembre est le mois des
vents d'orge et bien octobre est bien
celui des foires aux vins et qu'il y va
dit tout naturellement région du
bordelais et c'est justement là où je
vous emmène avec front poireau de la
rédaction de télé 7 la chaîne du groupe
sud ouest
cette année ce qui vise la rive droite
organise sa 28e foire aux vins d'automne
exploite 12 magasins en france dont 900
situant nouvelle aquitaine ici les
foires aux vins sont une opération
commerciale parmi toutes celles qui sont
organisées tout au long de l'année
sur les 6000 références de vins qu'il
vend dans toutes ses boutiques 150 venus
de tous les vignobles français font
l'objet d'une mise en avant d'une
promotion commerciale à l'occasion de
cette foire aux vins giron planté son
directeur ne cache pas son objectif
vendre parc est plutôt qu'à la bouteille
ces dernières années ses clients à
acheter plutôt à l'unité durant les
foires aux vins plutôt qu'en volume
important jérôme planté souhaite
inverser la tendance est elle tout au
long de l'année vous pouvez en kicking
découvrir des tas de merveilles l'état
des pépites mais au niveau de cette
opération deux foires aux vins
l'idée est vraiment de remplir nos caves
avec des bons rapports qualité-prix fait
mal classés d'arrivée c'était plus
intermittent dans cette enseigne le
panier moyen de vent durant les foires
aux vins oscille entre 120 et 180 euros
par client chez cet autre cas vis de la
métropole on prend le contre-pied de
cette politique commerciale ici comme
dans ces deux autres boutiques de
l'agglomération bordelaise pas de foire
aux vins pas d'opérations spéciales
durant l'automne antoine pujol dort et
son propriétaire estime que ces
opérations commerciales ont tendance à
trop de tirer les prix vers le bas il ne
souhaite pas marcher sur les
plates-bandes des grands de distribution
organisatrice historique de ces foires
aux vins n'a pas le même positionnement
on travaille on travaille à l'année avec
des vignerons plutôt des petites
structures pour l'essentiel casser les
prix cassés pas simplement nos marges
mais également les prix des vignerons
c'est effectivement pas non politique a
contrario plutôt qu'une foire aux vins
ce qu'alice préfère organiser des
rencontres des dégustations entre les
vignerons et ses clients pour faire la
promotion d'un vin qu'il vend dans ses
boutiques
le groupe des foires aux vins d'automne
a commencé à la mi septembre elles vont
durer jusqu'à la mi octobre en fonction
des enseignes
voilà puis après le vin voici un autre
plaisir celui ci à consommer sans
modération mais avec raison c'est le
chocolat des artisans chocolatiers vous
allez voir d'epinal en concoctant de
très spécial puisqu'il s'agit d'un 100%
made in france ils ont accepté d'ouvrir
les portes de leurs ateliers pour nous
est de révéler une partie des secrets de
fabrication à louise amanda et thierry
là sont de vosges télévision
ces fèves de cacao sont françaises tout
droit venus de martinique elles seront
concassés affiné transformé par ces
chocolatier spinaliens un chocolat
français de la cabosse à la tablette
c'est une première pour cet artisan
l'année dernière on a fait un arrivage
de bolivie venezuela trinitad sao tomé
et puis là je dis maintenant on va
peut-être changer c'est vrai qu'on va
essayer d'avoir un chocolat 100% bon
l'avantagé d'avoir un petit peu étaient
dans tous ces pays c'est qu'on sait
exactement
quel fèves qu'elle produit et puis
surtout c'est la torréfaction qui va
nous faire développer un petit peu la
rom de chaque pays c'est à dire sao tomé
c'est une île volcanique forcément vous
n'avez pas le même chocolat qu'au
venezuela
direction la martinique où le chocolat a
selon les palais un goût boisé parfois
d'agrumes les chocolatiers ont choisi de
collaborer avec une vosgienne installés
au sud de l'île depuis 30 ans elle
travaille dans le tourisme et connaît
bien la famille je suis né à epinal et
j'ai habité quelques années au dessus de
la chocolaterie lamielle ce n'était pas
un hasard puisque quelques années plus
tard en fait ma mère présidente des
floréales musicale d'epinal ce qu'on ne
savait pas que c'était chocolaterie
lamielle ça fait donc trente deux ans
que je suis en martinique maintenant et
j'habite sur une ancienne petite
habitation cacaoyère elle a épousé un
martiniquais et là bas en martinique et
là une petite plantation quelques arbres
quelques cas carlier a eu réellement
envoyer des fèves gentiment c'est je
pense extraordinaire parce que c'est
très très rare du cacao 100% français
c'est exceptionnel petit bémol le cacao
martiniquais est rare et son prix élevé
comptait 24 euros le kilo le double que
le tarif moyen du cacao issu des gros
pays producteurs sur l'île la filière
s'organise et la production augmente
depuis trois ans alors le chocolatier a
une petite idée
nous on voulait la martinique alors la
martinique ont la martinique guyane
c'est top l'idéal c'est d'avoir un peu
de terrain en guadeloupe qui partir
directement donc de la plantation de
l'arbre ça c'est vraiment le crac
un projet en réflexion pour les
chocolatiers spinaliens la maison amiel
vont chaque année une quinzaine de
tonnes de produits finis
[Musique]
voilà on ouvre une page culture dans ce
journal avec du théâtre mais du théâtre
pour se rapprocher pour créer du lien ou
tout simplement pour passer un moment de
convivialité
eh bien c'est ce que propose la houlala
compagnie dans le quartier populaire de
mort e à sablé-sur-sarthe et laure
virard de lmtv notre partenaire sur
place a pu assister à une de leurs
répétitions regardée
essayer ou lapin
ou l'album cette belle énergie les
habitants du quartier de nombreux à
sablé-sur-sarthe la partage avec les
artistes professionnels de la houlala
compagnie il s'agit pour l'instant de
découvrir l'univers de molière est l'un
de ces personnages emblématiques pour un
gentil trouve que lanson l'écriture
molière c'était voilà j'ai trouvé la
solution d'utiliser le rire pour
dénoncer les vices de notre société et
déjà rien que cette phrase de ce grand
artiste
molière ça résonne bien chez nous on
aime bien aussi sa bouffonnerie et en
même temps sa subtilité nadine martin
marie carmen et les autres ne sont pas
comédienne professionnelle mais
l'atelier théâtre au coeur de leur
quartier est une opportunité qu'elle
n'aurait raté pour rien au monde on fait
plein de choses la lecture du théâtre
c'est très varié et j'adore j'ai fait un
essai et puis ben voilà maintenant je
suis là à chaque fois qu'ils aient des
ateliers je dirais aujourd'hui de
quelqu'un que j'ai vu tout petit je
dirais non mais on t'a vu n'était pas
plus haut que ça et là il va falloir que
je dise nous vous avons vu que vous
n'étiez pas plus haut que ça un peu plus
dur
pas facile mais réjouissant l'objectif
de la houlala compagnie monter le
bourgeois gentilhomme en juin 2022 parc
du château de sable on les armes on
essaie de ça déjà en gros faut lui faut
lui faire peur
j'ai cependant ce journal avec du rugby
et la reprise des entraînements de
l'équipe des gazelles us à limoges après
deux ans d'interruption pour cause de
crise sanitaire c'est benjamin delmas le
chanceux de 7 à limoges qu'a rencontré
des joueuses visiblement très heureuse
de retrouver le chemin du stade
comme un air de rentrée sur les terrains
de rugby de haut blanc les gazelles de
l'usa limoges ont rechaussé les crampons
il repris le chemin de l'entraînement
avec beaucoup de plaisir et brandi après
les nombreuses attentes mais on at on a
plus que hâte parce que ça fait deux ans
qu'on en peut plus qu'on arrive à deux
matchs par année et là on a vraiment
envie d'aboutir une saison dignement et
à fond il yal'envie a vraiment ouais on
a hâte on attend que ça et on voit tout
le sourire sur le visage de chacune à
chaque entraînement donc ces problèmes
pour cette saison le staff des gazelles
s'est étoffée avec l'arrivée de simon
dexi ndour en provenance du rc guéret le
nouvel entraîneur aura la charge du
collectif charles ray encadre les avants
et morgane boulot les lignes arrières
quatre heures d'entraînement
hebdomadaire avec au programme des
ateliers pour retrouver des sensations
avec le ballon
on a repris petit à petit avec l'intégré
le contact parce que il ya des fictions
pas joué pendant un bon moment donc du
coup c'était reprendre sur du contact
arrivée sur du rugby du rugby réel avec
des contacts réels mais en évitant d'en
blesser donc du coup on a fait on est
parti sur une reprise avec en montant le
contact crescendo et là maintenant mais
on est sûr installer le plan de jeu ça
va être encore des beaux déplacements
avec des yeux culte qu'on connaît pas du
tout des équipiers en vue comme nous
souffrir du coc visée qui sont qui sera
organisée quoi qui sera d'apt à sa tête
un nouveau mode de fonctionnement après
je pense que même à chacun de tirer son
épingle du jeu on verra bien
on dit outre le 4 octobre les gazelles
quatre ans
[Musique]
voilà comme je vous l'annonçais dans les
titres de ce journal on termine par une
partie de l'amour sharon stone orlando
bloom gaspard ulliel et mélanie laurent
se sont donnés rendez vous sur le tapis
rouge du 5e gala pour la santé
planétaire à monaco et nos confrères de
monaco info sandrine jean
alexandre d'ordre et louis borgia ou
tuent les rencontres et les chanceux
regardez ce reportage tourné à monte
carlo cette semaine un lieu de prestige
pour une soirée qui l'était tout autant
après leonardo dicaprio orlando bloom
robert redford et sting l édition 2021
de l'événement a récompensé une femme
connue pour ses performances au cinéma
basic instinct l'expert mort ou vif ou
encore casino et pour son engagement en
faveur de causes nobles la lutte contre
le sida par exemple depuis de nombreuses
années sharon stone se mettent aussi en
faveur de la planète
cinquième édition de ce gala qui restera
associé à deux premières première
récompense pour une femme sharon stone
donc et autres premières l'événement
avait lieu dans la cour d'honneur du
palais princier cour où se trouvaient de
6 relents de bloem le héros de pirates
des caraïbes est un habitué du ghana
pour la santé planétaire en soutien aux
actions de la fondation prince albert ii
et cette année à de la fondation
princesse charlene plus proche de nous
dans l'hexagone deux artistes s'engagent
particulièrement gaspard ulliel qui
avait signé la tribune cinéma pour le
climat et mélanie laurent avec son
documentaire 2000 aurait fallu la paix
hier au départ et j'ai la raison que
personne ne prend conscience de ce
timing est très urgent donc on passe
notre temps à parler de scénario
alarmiste
autant ici on se réunit pour être sûr de
trouver des solutions autant eux se
réunissent pour parler de ce qui va pas
et dire que vraiment ça va pas à l'heure
actuelle on arrivé à un stade où on a
tous une mission face à cette
préoccupation qui est malheureusement
aujourd'hui devenu une réelle priorité
je pense aussi bien dans
les actions individuelles que surtout au
sein des actions communes avec les
gouvernements les investisseurs je pense
que tout le monde doit se mobiliser et
effectivement si moi je peux utiliser ma
petite notoriété pour essayer de
sensibiliser encore davantage les gens
sur sur ces questions là qui sont
devenus je trouve d'une priorité absolue
aujourd'hui une priorité aujourd'hui
pour un demain plus un océan terre et
humanité était une fois encore à
l'honneur à mener qu artiste décideurs
et philanthrope ont uni leurs forces
pour le bien commun à travers notamment
cette prestigieuse vente aux enchères
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivi
sur vos chaînes locales de la tnt et sur
tv5 monde on se retrouve très vite pour
une prochaine édition
bon courage à tous
[Musique]